hey guys healthy go and it was a video
that some of you have been waiting for
quite some time
it's part 2 of D hoarding my office
that's officially officially put
together now it's figuring out where
everything's gonna go let's look at all
this stuff we'll go stuff I have over
here that all needs a home
I'm sure must be realized that I have a
huge gaming and apple addict so over the
course of the years yes I have collected
many Apple products a lot of random
equipment for creating those ahead
YouTube videos so each one of these
things actually does have a use that
most of you guys might not realize is
how much time effort actually goes into
creating YouTube videos it may seem like
how you just shoot something and post it
no that's not the case I recently did
upgrade to the new 27-inch iMac because
the computer that I was using before
that was one that I want on the price is
right back in 2009 for century way with
his MIDI keyboard a brand new Apple
Computer
actually do still use this computer for
rendering I can be rendering out other
videos and still editing and not be
interrupted
this purple monitor here is my PC it's a
fantastic origin PC and obviously fits
my personality this freakin computer is
such a beast it definitely puts my Mac
to shame and it's my xbox Wii U monitor
so I use this when I'm playing my games
and capturing to capture I use the
Elgato Game Capture HD which is this
little guy right here so depending upon
which system I'm using I just switch out
the HDMI cables and I'm good to go
so this little area here kinda seems out
of place I do move this stuff around
when I'm shooting and I do tend to use
these quite often I think the hardest
thing for me when organizing was trying
to find a place for everything because I
have so many random thing but I did
manage to try to find a place for
everything this here I've organized and
labeled basically everything from
firewire cables to USB to USB minis
through if there's ever something that I
need and then I'm missing it's probably
in one of these containers
I'm actually so proud of my deboarding
that I got a well I guess you could call
it a compliment for a hoarder from :
O'Brien saying no my office was so bare
that he was going to come and be my
intern and help me decorate Justine you
are in Los Angeles or you're in a very
nice space there is that your apartment
where are you this is kind of my home
studio office well you have a very nice
and spare aesthetic in your apartment
it's very minimal yeah you're a
minimalist and she's a minimal yeah I
think in the background you could use a
poster for the internship
Conan you're not wrong I'm gonna sit as
I've done with it let me know Justine
I'm get up that's it I'm going to bring
that over personally in fact I like to
go for something if I could if you would
like to intern as an interior designer
maybe you could throw up a couple of
photos it would be the worst thing in
the world go I will do that I will be an
intern for Justine and I will design
your apartment that's what I'm going to
do I have like a little plant fake thing
here and oh that's gonna go I'm getting
we're getting rid of that it's gone
Justine Justine quick question we're
Spencer to work for you where would he
is there space for him there is he gonna
work you know we're a little cramped at
the moment so I'm so very Miami Vice
kinda it really does look like you are
working for Pablo Escobar
so Conan I'm holding you to that
work starts Monday bring your own lunch
doo doo doo doo de doo doo
knew that my friends is my office desk
tour I hope you guys enjoyed it I'll see
you guys later and if you'd like be sure
to add video responses here to this
video of your rooms or your offices I'll
see you guys later
right another again another shell
doesn't matter it's gonna get all
grounded up mixed it up real good
because at ease to the bottom